we have a release date for Strange New
World season two and Strange New World
season 3 has been green lit as well as
Lower Deck season five
this is exciting and we have a few more
little hints about what might be
happening with the new Star Trek series
as well welcome to side track your
Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so the news that slandered today that
actually strange new worlds will be
getting the third season and lower decks
will be getting a fifth season is a
little of a surprise but if you're a
regular Star Trek you'll know that last
week I started dropping a couple of
videos from a contact that I know that
has been working in and around Paramount
he actually works for a different
company but they've been doing some
outsourced work for Paramount which has
allowed them to get a little bit of an
insight about what the Paramount
executives are thinking
now
this kind of makes sense following on
from the meetings that this person this
Source I spoke to attended last week now
he has said to me and I've Heard lots of
rumors previously that actually Alex
kurtzman is not particularly well
trusted with the Paramount Executives
they believe he talks a big game but he
doesn't always follow through and
actually that they have said that the
stuff that Alex kurtzman creatively has
not been as as involved in
has been far more successful now my
source told me that he believes from
what he was told by parenting Mount
Executives that the brand new series of
Star Trek will be showrun by Terry
metallis that that is what the Paramount
executives are telling secret hideout
Alex kurtzman company that they want
metallis to return for the new series
that they are really really happy with
the response that the trekkies have had
to Picard season three that they really
believe Terry Miss Alice saved the
Picard Trilogy of series and that they
really think he is the man to take Star
Trek forwards Now secret hideout are the
production company they make the
television series for Paramount so they
don't I suppose really have to follow
this direction but at the end of the day
Paramount is saying you will or we won't
buy this Star Trek series so rock in a
hard place situation so what I've
actually been told and what does it mean
for this thing forwards well as I said
for a long time now Alex kurtzman has
not been well trusted I'm being told
that it was actually very true that
Paramount was seriously considering not
moving forwards with secret hideout at
all that there would have been no
further Star Trek from secret hideout
and that would have potentially even
meant no season three of strange new
worlds which is why it's taken so long
to get this announcement today because
they were seriously considering not
doing it
now it comes in a little bit more of a
problem this because secret hideout do
actually own certain elements of the
rights to the Strange New World Series
so now in theory Paramount could have
removed strange new worlds from secret
hideout and given it to a different
production company
but legally apparently and contractually
there would have been some problems with
that so that's again another reason why
this has taken so long to get this
announcement that we've been waiting for
now there would have also been of course
a knock-on effect with lower decks if
they had have decided to pull the plug
on secret hideout meaning that it would
again be more difficult to continue with
that as well so
today really is evidence of what I was
told last week that they have decided to
move forward to secret hideout we will
be seeing less Star Trek that is just
the way of it the empowerment wants to
spend way less money on these projects
and one way they can do that is they
will not be replacing Picard and
Discovery with two seasons of something
different we will get one series
following that and that is going to be
something led by Terry matalis
we will be getting more lower Decks that
is a very popular project with Paramount
they love it they like that it's a bit
different they like that actually it
draws in a different kind of audience we
are getting a second season of Prodigy
but that was announced a long time ago
the fact that it hasn't been announced
today does also suggest that what I was
told last week is also probably true
that they're seriously considering
canceling Prodigy after the second
season they really like it they love it
but it's not getting the impact that um
lower decks and stranger wolves is
getting so that is sort of like a good
third place but unfortunately that's not
good enough to keep it round
and again we will be having an
announcement regarding a third live show
one run potentially by Terry mattalis
within the next six to nine months
now this again could be Star Trek Legacy
I'm hearing that that's very possible
and it could get one season that
requires significant development work
and the one idea is for really to Bush
to be a follow-on almost like a Picard
season four but without Picard in it
um I actually really love that idea I
think I'd love to see where the Titan
goes from the end of this series I'd
love to see Seven of Nine Movies Captain
some of the crew that are aboard there
maybe Jack Crusher goes with them for
some reason
stranger things have happened another
idea though is that um he will be
allowed to do something completely
different man my understanding is that
the two other main projects that have
been talked a lot by Alex kurtzman about
are section 31 and Stafford Academy now
there are major reservations at
Paramount about Starfleet Academy it has
been pitched to them apparently several
times each time a little bit differently
you know give them feedback so now we
don't like this we don't like that come
back and secret hideout Alex kurtzerman
keeps coming back and pitching it again
they've never quite liked the idea and
it's possible but at the moment I'm
being told unlikely I'm also being told
though that section 31 is something the
Paramount executives are very excited by
if Michelle yo can do it if Michelle yo
isn't going to do it which again seems
unlikely that they're not so Keen now
lots of things between lower decks and
actually Picard season 3 is building up
towards section 31. they've been
mentioning it quite a lot because that
was always the plan
but following Michelle Yos and her Oscar
Victory well deserved it seems now less
likely now Michelle yo apparently does
have sort of a pre-contract agreement
with secret hideout to do
um section 31 but that isn't actually an
obligation it's basically a contract to
say that when you tell me when you want
to do it we will have a conversation and
this is kind of the thing I'd be willing
to do that's where we're at at the
moment just to recap
season three is definitely happen
Strange New World season 2 will be
airing in June this year we're getting
lower decks this summer and we will be
getting at least season five as well
possibly season six because the animated
stuff does tend to get
um commissioned or ordered in blocks of
20 so let's see what happens there
we will not be getting any news
apparently about replacing Picard and
um Discovery until around the time
Discovery airs so that could be six to
nine months so that's the news for Star
Trek moving forwards I'd love you guys
to get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think though the future
of Star Trek now does finally seem to be
secure the doubters seem to have made
their minds up and the decision has been
made but what do you think about the
decision they've gone with
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you want to support the channel even
more go to patreon.com forward slash
sidetrackware for a small fee each month
you can see most of our videos before
everybody else and it really supports
the channel you also get a mug and stuff
once you've been a member for three
months so all good stuff there's also
loads of links in the description for
everything Sidetrack related please go
join us on Facebook and Instagram blah
blah blah blah as always please stay
safe enjoy Picard tomorrow and I'll see
you soon
foreign